e aí mulher aí galera que assistir o
canal tudo vocês comigo luta' olha tá
tudo bem inclusive lei não está muito
melhor porque senti a dor que está
fazendo usuário do satanás da impressão
qualquer o sesi vai voar é igual ao meu
pescoço de começar a ouvir eu queria
pedir um negócio pra você o português
fernando escudeiro vídeo novo cabelo
vídeo novo boto vídeo novo às vezes eu
acabei de postar o vídeo ea pessoa não
sabe que eu postei um vídeo porque
porque não me segue nas redes sociais
então o seguinte aqui embaixo a
descrição do vídeo tem um link da canon
e você clica em ler mais embaixo tem
todo me redes sociais facebook instagram
e twitter deixa eu falar facebook toda
vez que o porta-voz a postar um vídeo
novo e tal taça obtida é importante é
muito importante que você curta apostar
no instagram toda vez que salva de novo
eu tiro print lá no youtube e bom posta
fotos instagram vídeo novo talvez seja a
miniatura do vício e já vê qualquer um
do vídeo e se corre lá no youtube vai
assistir não só me segue não estavam
também no twitter toda vez estava em 9
também posta um vídeo novo link do vídeo
e você pode assistir até lá mesmo em
maio no twitter antes de sair o vídeo
enquanto está sendo enviados e
conversando com as pessoas respondem
todo mundo no twitter
enquanto o vídeo está sendo enviado
então também é muito importante você me
seguir no twitter pra poder não perder
então caso você me sair do facebook me
segue no twitter que me segue estagnado
se você pt eu saltar não quer que você
aceite meu ver você me seguir no twitter
é muito difícil você pergunta então aqui
na descrição do vídeo tem um link 7 só
vai pois a seguir você vai no seu
instagram - só digitar o endereço no
estudo junto e segue é isso aí exigiu
foi nesse dia não vou sempre chopeiro
pra [ __ ] acho engraçado quando a
gente entra no shopping a primeira coisa
que a gente vê aquela promoção zona do
bob promoçom do bob r$6 o sanduíche você
pensa [ __ ] [ __ ] r$6 sanduíche eu vou
comprar você vai pedir um sanduíche de
r$6 adiciona queijo e bacon senhor você
pensa não são queixas e reais é possível
do kgb que o faça idéia de beleza cênica
de baby na quarenta e cinco reais e que
deseja dividir se não alcançar isso aí o
cartão no carnê não vou cancelar esse
pedido aí passa nada promissora assim o
céu fica para gente que diabo e queijo
bacon satã
dobrar o preço do sanduíche em alimentos
e já fica na praça de alimentação ruim
da praça de alimentação que ele tem um
cheiro de todas as comidas juntas abs
eficácia que ele pulasse ano
agora o bom é que você identificar o
cheiro de cada cor
bob bob's um samba e samba rock do mundo
porque não gosta de chope é o preço das
coisas é comprar pipoca no mercado de
lado o que 2 50 no shopping 2 50 ligado
no corpo e um saco de pipoca e o dia de
comprar pipoca no shopping e comprar a
tv de 32 polegadas aqui do mercado agora
porque me tira do sério e do outro o
dodo tudo isto não vai ficar esse
controle dualshock um tempo na andre é
que sempre sabe domingo é o dia que mais
tem jeito no shopping as velhinhas
resolve puxou tudo isso aí não pode
puxar também não olhe que anda verno
pané pois sabe que não pode emprestar da
chave pode fechar o dirigente pode agora
o negócio é que ela não sabe caminhar em
fila indiana sabe dançar pra me matar
outras têm que caminhar se a tudo de
lado se elas formam uma barreira no
corredor
yane caminha devagar a agenda caminho a
gente quer passar é velho e não deixem
não pode falar nada que venha ver no
evento tem moral se levantar e gritar
sim meu tempo a assassina swat 10km mapa
ea gente fica andando devagar dentro
dela uma senhora que elas conversam
senhora queria passar aqui é porque a
lei
ela tá ela tá twitter sabe é mesmo pois
sério gente melhor senhor poderia dar
certo que só pouco passar quietinha
cláudia mulher não sabe
meio que foi mulher o irmã cláudia tá
com derrubo que esse assassino deixar
passar bem que eu vou atacar um derrame
na senhora
[Música]
aqui para eu vou ter que procurar nele é
sempre assim é e nunca deixou passar por
que venha tudo venha tem moral deveria
falar assim eu não vou sair daqui não
posso fazer nada porque ela venha
tiverem agora às vezes um workshop tem
muita gente que tem um lugar do que eu
diz tim todas coisas tudo na nossa vida
que faz quem me diz passe vergonha é o
shopping porque tem muita gente o
destino mais que a gente passar vergonha
no meio de dois três quatro cinco
pessoas não têm que ser 10 mil pessoas
na festa é saber que ainda não passar
vergonha no shopping não me lembro de
uma vez menino mas foi mas foi por um
triz que não passei por ela estava como
espaguete à bolonhesa lembro como se
fosse hoje eu estava com o menino estava
comendo com tanta vontade só deixa eu
tava comendo com tanta vontade eu
coloquei o espaguete na boca eu estava
com muita vontade e deixou encantado com
tanta vontade que eu peguei assim ó a
colher zonas piloto eymael loteria e
macarrão me passar aqui na boca no que
eu paguei na boca foi um grãozinho de
carne moída não só um pedaço bem
pequenininhas inla fundo da minha
garganta mas eu armei uma tosse ou amigo
por exemplo eu juro para vocês mas eu
juro pra vocês que eu sou muito se por
amor por aquelas pessoas que estavam
livres eu torci 5 mil
pense no irão chama nagasato que
aconteceu naquele chão pode sim aparecer
no meio de história a revolta do materno
para o seguro e eu aprendi a lágrima
desceu a lágrima de seu eu peguei o
cópia fiel domingo lidas eta seca feito
um carro é tanto o macarrão na minha
boca do que aquele cop a fiat é nada e
foi assim na senha e boas tenha da silva
ganha tempo
é para aí meus amigos olha pra mim assim
o galera como vocês bom para você e do
shopping é um dinheiro que quando o cara
vai sim dinheiro só para nada de bom em
beber silva nando e agora além da
primeira vez que eu fui no shopping
estourado mesmo cheio da grana
[Música]
caco do jato cactus to doido olha também
com essa tua cara de 5 e dizer pra mim
tu ia sair daqui sem clicar em gostei
não tô com tanta quando meu coração eu
também acho uma coisa que pensar então
não 888 doido tô aqui gostei página nós
eu quero você comente aqui embaixo qual
foi informada engraçada e por mais
estranho que já aconteceu ontem foi no
shopping e se a primeira vez será aqui
que me inscrevesse que toda vez que
tiver vindo você vai saber é aquela que
eu falei no início virei aqui embaixo
você clica em ler mais têm todas minhas
redes sociais você me segue aí para você
não perder nenhum vídeo caseiro você me
segue ou só no twitter ou no facebook ou
somente na grand am e aí você acaba que
perde alguns vídeos não seguem todos que
não tem perigo de você perder algum
vídeo então vou ter que encerrar esse
vídeo logo é porque eu tenho muita coisa
a fazer trabalhando agora estou muito
ocupado com coisa muito importante é
isso aí até mais falou